Many of you may have spent the past few weeks exchanging gifts with family and friends, and maybe you're now enjoying some new possessions, or returning those that didn't fit or weren't quite what you wanted. Perhaps you're going through your old stuff, following through on a New Year's resolution to declutter. So it seems like a good time of year to talk about possessions and what possessions mean to us. The things we own can be central to our identity, according to some researchers, part of how we see ourselves and how other people see us.
你们中的许多人可能在过去几周里与家人和朋友交换了礼物，也许现在正享受着新物品带来的快乐，或者正在退掉那些不合身或不尽如人意的礼物。也许你正在整理旧物，践行新年清理杂物的决心。因此，现在似乎是一年之中谈论“拥有物”以及它们对我们意味着什么的绝佳时机。一些研究人员认为，我们拥有的东西可能是我们身份的核心，是我们看待自己以及他人看待我们方式的一部分。
So what role do possessions play in our lives? Why are many people driven to acquire things, especially to systematically collect items such as stamps, art, antique cars, or even matchbooks or PEZ dispensers? What does it mean to own something? To possessions have to be physical objects, or can they be digital or completely intangible? What happens when we have to give,
那么，拥有物在我们的生活中扮演着什么角色？为什么许多人热衷于获取物品，特别是系统性地收集邮票、艺术品、古董车，甚至是火柴盒或PEZ糖果机？拥有某样东西意味着什么？拥有物必须是实物吗？还是可以是数字化的，或者是完全无形的？当我们不得不放弃，
things up, when we downsize or declutter or lose a treasured possession? And how has the rise of the digital age and the sharing economy change the way people think about the importance of possessions? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Russell Belk, a distinguished research professor and Craft Foods Canada chair in marketing at the Shulik School of Business at York University in Ontario. Dr. Belk studies the meaning of possessions collecting gift-giving, sharing, and materialism. His research interests include understanding what our possessions mean to us, how different cultures
当我们精简生活、清理杂物或失去一件珍贵的物品时，会发生什么？数字时代的兴起和共享经济如何改变了人们对拥有物重要性的看法？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是罗素·贝尔克博士，他是约克大学舒立克商学院的市场营销学杰出研究教授和加拿大克拉夫特食品公司主席。贝尔克博士研究拥有物、收藏、赠礼、分享和物质主义的意义。他的研究兴趣包括理解我们的拥有物对我们意味着什么，不同文化如何
regard consumption, and how we relate to each other through possessions. Dr. Belk is the author of more than 650 journal articles and books. He is a past president of the Association for Consumer Research and has received numerous awards for his work, including being elected a fellow of the Royal Society of Canada. Dr. Belk, thank you for joining us today. Thank you for having me. It's pleasure. One of your most influential research papers is called Possessions and the Extended Self. So let's start with that. What does it mean to think of our possessions as extensions of our self? Well, if you look at something like a musical instrument or a mechanical aid like a hammer or a screwdriver, these literally extend the body.
看待消费，以及我们如何通过拥有物与他人建立联系。贝尔克博士撰写了650多篇期刊文章和书籍。他曾任消费者研究协会主席，并因其工作获得了无数奖项，包括当选为加拿大皇家学会院士。贝尔克博士，感谢您今天加入我们的节目。谢谢邀请，这是我的荣幸。您最具影响力的研究论文之一是《拥有物与扩展的自我》。那么，让我们从这里开始。将我们的拥有物视为自我的延伸意味着什么？嗯，如果你看看乐器或像锤子、螺丝刀这样的机械辅助工具，它们实际上扩展了身体。
They allow us to do things that we can't do with just our voice or with just our hands. But when we get into symbolic possessions, these are things that represent us. I'm in a household where we just got a new puppy. And the puppy is being trained. and sometimes it does well and sometimes it doesn't do well. And rather like our children, if they do something wonderful, we're related. If they do something terrible, we are sort of shame that it's our fault in a sense because these children, these companion animals are extensions of ourselves.
它们让我们能够做一些仅靠声音或双手无法完成的事情。但当我们谈到象征性的拥有物时，这些东西代表了我们。我住的家里刚养了一只小狗。小狗正在接受训练，有时表现得很好，有时则不然。就像我们的孩子一样，如果它们做了很棒的事情，我们会感到欣慰；如果它们做了糟糕的事情，我们会在某种意义上感到羞愧，觉得这是我们的错，因为这些孩子、这些伴侣动物是我们自我的延伸。
And so in that sense, we wax and we wane depending upon how our possessions prosper. Imagine, for example, that you just got a new piece of clothing and you spill tomato soup all over it. Or you just get a new automobile and you have a little fender scraper. It's almost like your body is being scraped or damaged or soiled. And so in that sense, in a nutshell or in a capsule, these are possessions that not only extend what we can do, but they represent us. they have symbolic meaning. Many people think of possessions as things that we own in a physical or a legal sense, but your definition is broader than that.
因此，从这个意义上说，我们的情绪会随着拥有物的状况而起伏。例如，想象一下你刚买了一件新衣服，却不小心把番茄汤洒在了上面。或者你刚买了一辆新车，却发生了一点刮擦。这感觉就像你的身体被刮伤、损坏或弄脏了一样。所以，简而言之，这些拥有物不仅扩展了我们的能力，还代表了我们，它们具有象征意义。许多人认为拥有物是我们从物理或法律意义上拥有的东西，但您的定义比这更广泛。
How far can the definition of possession stretch? Well, that's a good question. And it's one that has more salience, as you pointed out in your introduction, because of the sharing economy that we have gotten into and because of the digital economy that we're all a part of. And so we can own things that we do not possess and we can feel that we own something that is intangible. So students in a classroom, for example, that come and sit in the same non-assigned seat every day or every week, come to think about it as their seat. And if someone else is in it, they may be perturbed enough to actually ask the person to move.
拥有物的定义可以延伸到多远？嗯，这是一个好问题。正如你在介绍中所指出的，由于我们进入了共享经济，并且我们都是数字经济的一部分，这个问题变得更加突出。因此，我们可以拥有我们并不占有的东西，也可以感觉到我们拥有某种无形的东西。例如，教室里的学生每天或每周都坐在同一个非指定的座位上，他们会认为那是“他们的”座位。如果别人坐在那里，他们可能会感到不安，甚至会要求那个人离开。
or they may slink off and sit in another seat. So they're assuming that they own that possession, even though they don't own it. Or to take another example, children in the home, unless it's a very unusual home, don't have to knock on the door and ask if they can come in or whether they can sit down on the sofa. Even though these are possessions that are legally not theirs, they are de facto shared possessions. The family shares them. And unless it was a very unusual family, when you left home, you did not receive an itemized bill of everything your parents had spent on you, which they expected you to repay. And so this is sharing within the family, which is where the greatest amount of sharing takes place.
或者他们可能会默默走开，坐在另一个座位上。所以他们假设自己拥有那个拥有物，尽管他们并没有法律上的所有权。或者再举个例子，家里的孩子，除非是一个非常特殊的家庭，否则不需要敲门询问是否可以进来，或者是否可以坐在沙发上。尽管这些在法律上不属于他们，但它们是事实上的共享拥有物。家庭共享这些东西。而且，除非是一个非常特殊的家庭，否则当你离家时，你并没有收到一份父母为你花费的所有物品的明细账单，并被要求偿还。所以这是家庭内部的分享，这是分享发生最频繁的地方。
Now, when we go to the so-called sharing economy with Airbnb and Uber and other forms of sharing, we're not really sharing. We're doing something closer to short-term rental. And so it's not at all the feeling of ours rather than mine in yours. There's still a mine in yours. And people don't take care of possessions that they're renting on a short-term basis the same way they would the possession that they actually owned. So they may drive the car faster or they may leave the house or the home in less of a pristine condition than they might their own if they owned it.
现在，当我们进入所谓的共享经济，比如Airbnb、Uber和其他形式的分享时，我们并不是真的在分享。我们所做的事情更接近于短期租赁。所以，这根本不是“我们的”感觉，而不是“我的”和“你的”。这里仍然存在“我的”和“你的”之分。人们不会像对待自己真正拥有的物品那样去爱护短期租赁的物品。所以他们可能会开得更快，或者把房子或家留下的状况不如他们自己拥有时那样整洁。
And so we feel differently depending upon whether something is truly ours or whether it's shared. Now, when we get to the digital economy, it's also tricky. We used to, if you can see behind me, this I know it was going out just with audio, but if you can see behind me, there's a bookcase full of books. And as an academic, I have for many years now hung on to tangible physical books. but now part of my library is digital, and so I can just call it up on my computer. But there's a difference. When I shut my computer, I no longer have access to that book unless I can call it up on my smartphone, perhaps.
因此，根据某样东西是真正属于我们的还是共享的，我们的感受是不同的。现在，当我们谈到数字经济时，情况也很棘手。过去，如果你能看到我身后——我知道这只是音频节目，但如果你能看到我身后——有一个装满书的书架。作为一名学者，多年来我一直坚持保留实体的纸质书。但现在我的图书馆有一部分是数字化的，所以我可以在电脑上随时调取。但两者是有区别的。当我关掉电脑时，我就无法再访问那本书了，除非我能在智能手机上调取它。
And also, I don't know that, well, it's the red book over there on the third shelf, and I know if I open it to a certain page, I'm going to find something. So we access that information in a different way. We search for it and we sort of see it in a decontextualized way. And we've gotten farther than that. We have now streaming music, for example, in streaming movies. And so in place of the library of cassettes or even tapes before that, we have these things that we don't really have any tangible proof of.
而且，我不知道，嗯，那是第三层架子上的那本红书，我知道如果我翻到某一页，我就能找到某些东西。所以我们以不同的方式获取这些信息。我们搜索它，并以一种去语境化的方式看待它。我们已经走得更远了。例如，我们现在有流媒体音乐和流媒体电影。因此，取代了磁带库甚至之前的录音带，我们拥有了这些我们没有任何实物证明的东西。
And so people can't see our libraries and see how big or well-ordered or meaning. meaningful they are. They can't look at our music collection and say, I can see how you've ordered that and that's really interesting. And we can't prepare a mixed tape for someone or I suppose it was a mixed CD and mixed DVD after that. We maybe rather send them a playlist. And so people, and by people, especially referring to Generation Z, or we would say Z here in Canada, or millennials, are more used to having access rather than ownership. And so they don't feel the loss that some of us older people do when we have streaming access to something
所以人们看不到我们的图书馆，也无法看出它们有多大、整理得有多好或有多么有意义。他们无法查看我们的音乐收藏并说：“我能看出你是如何整理这些的，这真的很有趣。”我们也不能为某人制作混音带，或者我想后来是混音CD和混音DVD。我们可能更倾向于给他们发送一个播放列表。所以人们，我这里特别指Z世代（或者我们在加拿大称之为Z世代）或千禧一代，更习惯于拥有“访问权”而不是“所有权”。因此，当他们拥有流媒体访问权限时，他们不会像我们这些年长者那样感到失落，
rather than being able to go to our library and pull it out and know that it's ours. And for that matter, if we have avatars in an online world or an online gaming platform, and the gaming platform shuts down for some reason, our avatar is no longer there. Now, supposedly that's going to be different in the metaverse where we have interoperability and we're able to take our avatar from one world to another.
而不是能够走到我们的图书馆把它拿出来，并知道它是属于我们的。同样，如果我们在线世界或在线游戏平台中有化身，而游戏平台因某种原因关闭了，我们的化身就不再存在了。现在，据推测，在元宇宙中情况会有所不同，我们将拥有互操作性，能够将我们的化身从一个世界带到另一个世界。
But I don't know if we would want our Assassin's Creed or World of Warcraft avatar in Candyland or Animal Crossing or something of that sort. So there's a series of problems when we get into that realm. And let me just mention one more digital aspect. And then now we can come back to some of these things. if you'd like. If you look at some of the digital assets that have been marketed in the last five years, we come to things like NFTs, non-fundable tokens. And these are digital representations of something that don't even give us the access that we have to streaming books or streaming music
但我不知道我们是否希望我们的《刺客信条》或《魔兽世界》化身出现在《糖果传奇》或《动物森友会》之类的游戏中。所以当我们进入那个领域时，会有一系列问题。让我再提一个数字方面的例子。然后我们可以回到这些话题，如果你愿意的话。如果你看看过去五年中营销的一些数字资产，我们会接触到NFT，即非同质化代币。这些是某种东西的数字表示，甚至没有给我们提供像流媒体书籍、流媒体音乐
or streaming movies. Rather, we get an image of an artwork or an image of an avatar and we don't own the original, and we don't have the same sort of ownership rights that we would have if we do have, or did have, or own the original. There's another aspect to that, and that is that the artist can get some residual rights when our digital token is sold at a higher price, and they can get a claim, often 10% of that increase in value. And this goes back to an old 1972 auction of the skull collection in New York. And this was a collection of expressionist and pop art. And it was one where the auction was filmed. And there were also discussions between the artists and the collectors and some of the buyers.
或流媒体电影那样的访问权限。相反，我们得到的是一件艺术品的图像或一个化身的图像，我们并不拥有原件，也没有我们拥有或曾经拥有原件时所享有的那种所有权。这还有另一个方面，那就是当我们的数字代币以更高的价格出售时，艺术家可以获得一些剩余权利，他们可以获得索赔权，通常是增值部分的10%。这可以追溯到1972年纽约斯卡尔（Skull）收藏品的拍卖会。这是一场表现主义和波普艺术的收藏。拍卖过程被拍摄了下来。艺术家、收藏家和一些买家之间也进行了讨论。
And so Robert Rochenberg had one of his pieces. of art sold for something like $85,000, a small amount in today's world, but a large amount then. And he went to Skull, who sold it, and said, I sold you this thing for $400, something like that. And you've made this tremendous profit. I've worked my ass off for you, and I'm not getting anything out of it. And Skull said to him, well, I'm working my ass off for you. I'm increasing the value of your future artwork by escalating the prices and collecting your artwork. And so I guess that gets into another realm of collecting that maybe we can talk about later that you also brought up in your introduction.
罗伯特·劳森伯格（Robert Rauschenberg）的一件艺术品以大约8.5万美元的价格售出，在今天看来是一笔小数目，但在当时是一笔巨款。他找到卖掉这件作品的斯卡尔说：“我以400美元左右的价格把这东西卖给你。你却赚了这么多钱。我为你拼命工作，却什么也没得到。”斯卡尔对他说：“好吧，我也在为你拼命工作。我通过抬高价格和收藏你的艺术品，提高了你未来艺术品的价值。”所以我想这进入了收藏的另一个领域，也许我们稍后可以谈谈，这也是你在介绍中提到的。
But I'm skimming over things here. So please, if you'd like to come back to any of these things, feel free. Sure. And we may do that. But speaking of collecting, I know you've done a lot of research in that area. And I'm just wondering, what motivates people to collect things? Where does that drive come from? Well, I guess as children, we're sort of natural collectors that we see interesting things, and we bring them home.
但我在这里只是粗略地谈了一下。所以，如果你想回到这些话题中的任何一个，请随时提出。当然。我们可能会这样做。但说到收藏，我知道你在那个领域做了很多研究。我只是想知道，是什么激励人们去收藏东西？这种动力来自哪里？嗯，我想作为孩子，我们天生就是收藏家，我们看到有趣的东西，就把它们带回家。
And we tell our parents or show a friend, here's my collection of stuff. And they say, well, what kind of stuff? And that's not a collection. This is just some pebbles and sticks and other objects that you found on the ground. And it's not a collection because a collection has to obey some rules. And it should be in a singular category. And you should have one of a kind. You shouldn't hoard things by having lots and lots of the same thing.
我们告诉父母或向朋友展示：“这是我的收藏品。”他们会说：“什么种类的东西？这不算收藏。这只是一些你在地上捡到的鹅卵石、树枝和其他物体。”这不算收藏，因为收藏必须遵循一些规则。它应该属于一个单一的类别。你应该拥有独一无二的东西。你不应该通过囤积大量相同的东西来收藏。
And you should have some sort of sense of order and some sort of boundaries to this collection. And anyway, we learned to make good collections. good collections follow some sort of rules so we can describe what it is that we collect. Now, interestingly, collections often don't start out in a purposeful way that I'm going to collect X or Y or Z, but rather someone gives us a duck, and we know, not a real duck, a duck that's ceramic perhaps, and we have some other ducks made of wood or plaster in our home, and we look around and I say, I must be a duck collector. There's something about ducks that have adhered to me.
而且你应该对这个收藏有一种秩序感和某种界限。总之，我们学会了如何进行好的收藏。好的收藏遵循某种规则，这样我们就能描述我们收藏的是什么。有趣的是，收藏往往不是以一种有目的的方式开始的，比如“我要收藏X、Y或Z”，而是有人送给我们一只鸭子，我们家里可能还有一些木头或石膏做的鸭子，我们环顾四周，然后说：“我一定是个鸭子收藏家。”有些关于鸭子的东西已经吸引了我。
Nevertheless, when we begin to collect them, we find some joy in that, joy in bringing order, joy in creating a collection that it adheres somehow. It's greater than the sum of its parts because it is a part of a collection. And so one of the joys is that we have sort of a collection of a little world that we can control. We may not have control of our careers or our behavior on our jobs, and we don't have control of much of the exterior world, but we do have control of this collection. And it brings us joy when we're able to expand it and we're able to improve upon it. And for that matter, other collectors may admire us. Now, I should point out that the type of collection I've been talking about is one that does have some sense of coherence. And we could think of an old stamp collection or coin collection.
尽管如此，当我们开始收藏它们时，我们从中找到了一些乐趣，带来秩序的乐趣，创造一个以某种方式粘合在一起的收藏的乐趣。它大于其各部分的总和，因为它是一个收藏的一部分。所以乐趣之一是，我们拥有一个我们可以控制的小世界。我们可能无法控制我们的职业或我们在工作中的表现，我们也无法控制外部世界的大部分，但我们确实可以控制这个收藏。当我们能够扩展它并改进它时，它会给我们带来快乐。而且，其他收藏家可能会钦佩我们。现在，我应该指出，我一直在谈论的这种收藏是具有某种连贯性的。我们可以想到旧邮票收藏或硬币收藏。
And those were things where you could sort of fill in the boxes and you would know when it was complete. You had the entire series of coins of country A, B, or C, or you had filled up your stamp book with the stamps that were listed. But another type of, and we still have that sort of collection, but another sort of collection is one where we have a category, like we're going to be an art collector. But we're not confining ourselves to a particular genre, a particular period, a particular artist. We're just giving things that strike our eye. And, you know, someone could have, you know, a passion for yellow things, and they collect yellow things. Or they may have a passion for a particular style of painting or a particular medium in which the artist is working. And so they collect within a cat.
那些是可以填满方格的东西，你会知道什么时候它完成了。你拥有了A、B或C国的所有硬币系列，或者你已经用列出的邮票填满了你的邮票册。但另一种类型——我们仍然有那种收藏，但另一种收藏是，我们有一个类别，比如“我要成为一名艺术收藏家”。但我们并不局限于特定的流派、特定的时期、特定的艺术家。我们只是收集那些吸引我们眼球的东西。你知道，有人可能对黄色的东西有热情，他们就收集黄色的东西。或者他们可能对某种绘画风格或艺术家正在使用的某种媒介有热情。所以他们在类别内进行收藏。
But within that category, anything goes. And so they're not filling in the narrow boxes that a type A collector would be. A type A collector is a little bit like we refer to someone with a type A personality. Perhaps a bit ain't already to hit those. I might say they're collecting, but they're constrained by rules rather than letting their imagination and desires rule. Well, I was just going to ask a question here. I'm sorry to interrupt you, but it got me thinking because I know you've defined two types of collecting, aesthetic and taxonomic. It seems that you're talking about the two right now. Could you
但在该类别内，任何东西都可以。所以他们并没有填满A型收藏家会填满的狭窄方格。A型收藏家有点像我们所说的A型人格。也许有点急于求成。我可能会说他们在收藏，但他们受到规则的约束，而不是让他们的想象力和欲望来主导。嗯，我正要在这里问一个问题。抱歉打断你，但这让我开始思考，因为我知道你定义了两种收藏类型：审美型和分类型。你现在似乎正在谈论这两种。你能
explain how those are different? Yeah, taxonomic collection has, think of it as a two-by-two matrix, and we have some dimensions that we're trying to fulfill, and we're trying to collect one thing in each of those four boxes. And when we have it complete, we've completed the collection. We don't want to put more things in one of those boxes because we'd be duplicating in that case. We'd be hoarding rather than collecting. So that's a type A taxonomic collector. The type B aesthetic collector is looking for things that please the eye
解释一下它们有什么不同吗？是的，分类收藏，把它想象成一个二乘二的矩阵，我们有一些想要满足的维度，我们试图在每一个方格里收集一样东西。当我们完成它时，我们就完成了收藏。我们不想在那些方格里放更多的东西，因为那样我们就是在重复。那样就是囤积而不是收藏。所以那是A型分类收藏家。B型审美收藏家正在寻找那些取悦眼睛
or the ear or whatever it is that we're collecting within that sensory mode. Smells could be another thing that we might collect, for example, or places that we've traveled. But once we have that category, we're not saying, well, I'm going to collect all of the European countries by visiting all of the European countries. In that case, it would be more taxonomic. We're just going to say, I'm going to go to the places that interest me in the world. And I've never been to Peru, and so I think I'll go to Peru, and I think I'll go to Machu Picchu while I'm there. And so those are some of the things that might interest us in that case.
或耳朵，或者我们在该感官模式内收集的任何东西。例如，气味可能是我们可以收集的另一件事，或者我们去过的地方。但一旦我们有了那个类别，我们并不是说：“好吧，我要通过访问所有欧洲国家来收集所有欧洲国家。”在这种情况下，它会更偏向分类。我们只是说：“我要去世界上让我感兴趣的地方。”我从来没去过秘鲁，所以我想我会去秘鲁，我想在去那里的时候去马丘比丘。所以这些是在那种情况下可能让我们感兴趣的一些事情。
but I also want to go to Australia. I also want to see the kangaroos. So this is just following our curiosity or our aesthetic sense rather than trying to complete and take off the boxes. Now, you've said that collecting can be beneficial for some people. How so? Well, it can be therapeutic. It can be a way of doing something that we feel is meaningful.
但我还想去澳大利亚。我还想看袋鼠。所以这只是跟随我们的好奇心或审美感，而不是试图完成和勾选方格。现在，你说过收藏对某些人来说是有益的。怎么说呢？嗯，它可以是治疗性的。它可以是一种做我们觉得有意义的事情的方式。
Even though to the outside world, it may not. appear meaningful. We once did a visit to, and this was on a project where I was with a group of others, to Mr. Ed's Elephant Museum and Roadside Attraction near Gettysburg, Pennsylvania. And we stopped because we saw this huge bag of peanuts out in front. And it turned out that Mr. Ed, like some others in the Elephant Collector Society or the collectors of Alphantiana, shared. and that was a joy in collecting anything related to elephants, and it could be a poster, it could be a piece of music, it could be an oil can that was shaped like an elephant.
尽管对外界来说，它可能看起来并不有意义。我们曾经参观过——这是一个我和其他人一起参与的项目——位于宾夕法尼亚州葛底斯堡附近的埃德先生大象博物馆和路边景点。我们停下来是因为我们看到了前面那一大袋花生。结果发现，埃德先生像“大象收藏家协会”或其他“大象纪念品收藏家”中的其他人一样，分享着这种快乐。收藏任何与大象有关的东西都是一种乐趣，它可以是一张海报、一段音乐、一个形状像大象的油罐。
And he presented this to the public, and he had a shop where he also sold things, but that was entirely separate from the collections, and things would never go back and forth. But he said, in all honesty, standing in front of his roadside attraction and museum, history will someday stand in awe, of me and what I've accomplished here.
他把这些展示给公众，他有一个商店，他也卖东西，但这与收藏完全分开，东西永远不会来回流动。但他诚实地说，站在他的路边景点和博物馆前：“历史终有一天会敬畏我，以及我在这里所取得的成就。”
And so he felt in a vague way that he was contributing to art and or science by this objective that he had to collect all sorts of elephants. And because there were other elephant collectors that reinforced him in that belief, because other people stopped by the museum, he got some reinforcement for that idea. And who's to say that he's wrong? It may be unlikely that he's going to go down in the books of science or art as a, famous collector because this is a collection that would be regarded as trivial by many collectors who are really into their collection at the high end and hoping to profit from it.
所以他模糊地感觉到，通过他收集各种大象的目标，他正在为艺术和/或科学做出贡献。因为有其他大象收藏家在那种信念上支持他，因为其他人停下来参观博物馆，他从那个想法中得到了一些强化。谁能说他是错的呢？他不太可能作为一位著名的收藏家载入科学或艺术史册，因为这是一个会被许多真正投入高端收藏并希望从中获利的收藏家视为琐碎的收藏。
It used to be that most collectors might say something, well, like, this is for my retirement. I'm saving up and I will cash this out once I'm retired. But that was a pipe dream because a few other people wanted to buy these collections, at least few other people that were encountered. Now that we're able to go online to eBay and other similar equivalents, it's easier to sell a collection. So there's greater truth to that promise if we're collecting especially at the high end. But collecting brings different joys to different people. And part of it is, I think, just this ability to control a small world.
过去，大多数收藏家可能会说：“这是为了我的退休。我正在存钱，退休后我会把这些变现。”但这只是白日梦，因为很少有其他人想买这些收藏品，至少很少遇到其他人。现在我们能够上网到eBay和其他类似的平台，出售收藏品变得更容易了。所以，如果我们进行高端收藏，那个承诺的真实性就更高了。但收藏给不同的人带来不同的快乐。我认为，其中一部分只是这种控制一个小世界的能力。
So you mentioned the Internet in places like eBay where you can sell collections. So the Internet has clearly changed collecting. Has it made it more or less challenging for people, do you think? I think it's made it less challenging, in a sense, although you can refine your collection so that becomes more esoteric and equally difficult. But there are people like William Gibson who gave us the book that became the Matrix series of movies. And he said he loved watches, but he didn't want to collect because it was too much work. and would take him all over the world until eBay came along.
所以你提到了互联网和像eBay这样可以出售收藏品的地方。所以互联网显然改变了收藏。你认为它让人们变得更具挑战性还是不那么具挑战性了？我认为在某种意义上它变得不那么具挑战性了，尽管你可以细化你的收藏，使其变得更加深奥，同样困难。但像威廉·吉布森（William Gibson）这样的人，他给了我们那本后来成为《黑客帝国》系列电影的书。他说他喜欢手表，但他不想收藏，因为那太费力了，而且会让他跑遍世界各地，直到eBay出现。
And that made it easy enough to collect and actually find the watches that he wanted to enter into this collection. And so, as I say, it makes it easier. But if we develop even narrower rules of what we're trying to collect, we can still present ourselves with perhaps an equal challenge to what we might have had previously. So there's a saying that he who has the most toys wins. And that got me thinking, are men more inclined to collect than women? Have you found any differences between the sexes when it comes to collecting stuff? Historically, yes.
这使得收藏变得足够容易，并且实际上找到了他想要进入这个收藏的手表。所以，正如我所说，它让事情变得更容易了。但如果我们制定更狭窄的规则来决定我们要收藏什么，我们仍然可以给自己带来与以前可能遇到的同等挑战。所以有一句谚语说：“拥有最多玩具的人赢了。”这让我开始思考，男性是否比女性更倾向于收藏？在收藏东西方面，你有没有发现性别之间的任何差异？历史上，是的。
Men have been more inclined to or more able to collect. The men historically have had more control of the wealth than women have. Also, when men collect, it's regarded as it must be a purposeful and meaningful collection. When women collect, it's just you have all of this silly stuff. Why do you have these things? It's regarded more frivolously. And that's obviously a sexist bias, but I think it still persists in society. It may be that in patriarchal societies, men have more control of the pocketbook.
男性一直更倾向于或更有能力收藏。历史上，男性比女性拥有更多的财富控制权。此外，当男性收藏时，它被认为一定是一个有目的和有意义的收藏。当女性收藏时，它只是“你拥有所有这些愚蠢的东西。你为什么有这些东西？”它被认为更轻浮。这显然是一种性别偏见，但我认为它在社会中仍然存在。可能在父权制社会中，男性对钱包有更多的控制权。
They have more control of the spaces in which to exhibit their wealth. We once encountered a man and woman who both had collections. And he had a collection of fire brigade equipment from historically different eras in society. She had a collection of mice replicas. And sadly, that's sort of telling that she was collecting the miniature, delicate thing. He was collecting the rugged, masculine. They were clicking to the stereotypes of their genders, if you will. And so there is some gender bias in the sense of not only whether we collect, but what we collect as well.
他们对展示财富的空间有更多的控制权。我们曾经遇到过一对男女，他们都有收藏。他收藏了历史上不同时代的消防队设备。她收藏了老鼠复制品。可悲的是，这说明了她正在收集微小的、精致的东西。他正在收集粗犷的、阳刚的东西。他们符合了他们性别的刻板印象。所以，不仅在是否收藏方面，而且在收藏什么方面，确实存在一些性别偏见。
Well, it sounds as if you have encountered many, many different types of collections. I'm wondering if there are any that stick out in your mind as being among the most unusual or surprising. Well, there was a woman who collected dirt, which struck us as a little bit unusual. But she said, don't you see, this was dirt from Jerusalem. And this is dirt from Peru. And she had a nomenclature which would defy the eye. We've also had encountered people that collect ineffable sorts of objects like the types of planes that they've seen or the types of trains that they have seen are ridden on. And so these are things that like bird, what do you call it, bird watchers, are collecting birds in a sense.
嗯，听起来你遇到过许多许多不同类型的收藏。我想知道是否有任何收藏让你印象深刻，觉得是最不寻常或最令人惊讶的。嗯，有一位女士收集泥土，这让我们觉得有点不寻常。但她说：“你没看出来吗？这是来自耶路撒冷的泥土。这是来自秘鲁的泥土。”她有一套令人眼花缭乱的命名法。我们也遇到过人们收集一些难以言喻的物体，比如他们见过的飞机类型，或者他们见过或乘坐过的火车类型。所以这些东西就像观鸟者一样，在某种意义上是在收集鸟类。
but they're not collecting the physical birds. They're just collecting notebooks, and perhaps in some cases, photographs of the birds. And so we can collect experiences as well as tangible sorts of things. I have to out myself as a birder and admit that I do have one of those lists. Let's go back to more on what's happening in the world around possessions and the changing ways that we're viewing them. I've heard you say in another interview that you prefer the term collaborative consumption to sharing economy.
但他们并不是在收集实体的鸟。他们只是在收集笔记本，在某些情况下，可能是鸟类的照片。所以我们不仅可以收集实体的东西，还可以收集体验。我必须承认自己是一名观鸟者，并承认我确实有那样的一份清单。让我们回到关于拥有物周围正在发生的事情以及我们看待它们的方式的变化上。我在另一次采访中听到你说，你更喜欢“协作消费”这个词，而不是“共享经济”。
Why is that? Okay, collaborative consumption is the term that I'm using for the so-called sharing economy. And when we engage in the sharing economy, we're not really owning things. We are collaborating and using them. And so, for example, you might subscribe to rent the runway. and you pay a monthly fee, in an exchange for that, you can get as many handbags or designer outfits as you like. It's just that you have to return the former one before you get the next one sent to you.
为什么呢？好的，“协作消费”是我用来指代所谓“共享经济”的术语。当我们参与共享经济时，我们并不是真的在拥有东西。我们是在协作并使用它们。例如，你可能会订阅“Rent the Runway”。你支付月费，作为交换，你可以得到尽可能多的手提包或设计师服装。只是你必须在收到下一件之前归还前一件。
And so in this sense, you look like you have a fabulous wardrobe, but actually you just have access to rent the runway as long as you pay your subscription fees. That's not like a collection of actual handbags that you're. you can keep on a shelf and they will remain there. And it gives you a sense of having the entire collection rather than having access to it. Now, again, there may be a generational thing here. It may be that those of us who were not born digital think of these tangible things as somehow more real and more rewarding and more substantive and more important than the things we can access.
所以从这个意义上说，你看起来拥有一个很棒的衣橱，但实际上你只是拥有了“Rent the Runway”的访问权限，只要你支付订阅费。这不像你真正拥有的手提包收藏，你可以把它们放在架子上，它们会一直留在那里。它让你有一种拥有整个收藏的感觉，而不是拥有访问权限。现在，这里可能存在代际差异。可能我们这些非数字原住民认为这些实物在某种程度上比我们可以访问的东西更真实、更有回报、更充实、更重要。
But if you think about it, if you are what you access rather than you are, are what you have, you have a much broader sense of the world. If you don't have to own a vacation home, but you have access to vacation homes around the world, you're in a sense a broader sort of person that you can take advantage of more cultures and more places and so forth. Now, people get locked into sharing resources like rental unit, not rental units, but not share. A time share. time share apartments. And eventually they get tired of that and want to get out of it and all of the travel that would be involved in the paperwork and so forth is something that they don't enjoy. But nevertheless, in principle, you have access to a much greater array of things via the sharing economy than you would if you had to buy those things all on your own.
但如果你仔细想想，如果你是“你所访问的东西”而不是“你所拥有的东西”，你对世界的看法会更广阔。如果你不需要拥有一处度假屋，但你可以访问世界各地的度假屋，从某种意义上说，你是一个更广阔的人，你可以利用更多的文化和更多的地方等等。现在，人们被锁定在共享资源中，比如租赁单元——不是租赁单元，而是分时度假公寓。最终他们厌倦了这一点，想要摆脱它，所有涉及文书工作等的旅行都是他们不喜欢的。但尽管如此，原则上，通过共享经济，你比必须自己购买所有这些东西拥有了更广泛的资源访问权限。
Let's talk about another aspect of ownership, which is what happens when we have to give up things that, have been meaningful to us. Listen to an interview, you did where you talked about how helping your mother downsize changed your perspective somewhat on the meaning of possessions. Can you talk about that? I mean, how do we disentangle ourselves from things that have all of this meaning and help define who we are? Well, I'll come back to my mother.
让我们谈谈所有权的另一个方面，那就是当我们不得不放弃对我们有意义的东西时会发生什么。听过你的一次采访，你谈到帮助母亲精简生活在某种程度上改变了你对拥有物意义的看法。你能谈谈那个吗？我的意思是，我们如何将自己与那些具有所有这些意义并帮助定义我们是谁的东西分离开来？嗯，我会回到我母亲的话题。
It's a sensitive area of still for me. But if you think about children's toys, for example, and children's art productions from going to school, these are things that we save oftentimes. And at some point, after the children have grown up or left home, we realize that we may need to downsize or may simply need to clean up the clutter in our house. And we can't get rid of these things immediately
这对我来说仍然是一个敏感的领域。但如果你想想儿童玩具，例如，以及孩子们从学校带回来的艺术作品，这些往往是我们保存的东西。在某个时候，孩子们长大或离家后，我们意识到我们可能需要精简生活，或者可能只是需要清理房子里的杂物。我们不能立即摆脱这些东西
because they're so infused with memories. and they're hot possessions, if you will. And so if we put them away for a while in the attic or in the basement, these are places that are sort of liminal spaces where they can cool off a bit. And so when we've been distanced from them, they may not be as rich and saturated with memories as they were previously. Now, I found something similar with my mother, except that I live in Toronto and she lived in Minneapolis.
因为它们充满了记忆，如果可以的话，它们是“热的拥有物”。所以如果我们把它们在阁楼或地下室里放一段时间，这些地方是某种过渡空间，它们可以在那里冷却一下。所以当我们与它们保持距离后，它们可能不像以前那样充满记忆了。现在，我在我母亲身上发现了类似的情况，只是我住在多伦多，而她住在明尼阿波利斯。
I'm the only surviving relative. And so I had limited time available to dispossess her of all of these former possessions. Let me go through the stages, I guess. First, she moved from a house with a lot of space and a lot of yard to keep up. And after my father died, it got to be too much for her. So she moved into an adult community where people helped each other, but it wasn't really a care facility. Then she did move into a care facility. Now, at each of those stages, she had to downsize, and we had to jointly decide what to keep and what not to keep.
我是唯一的幸存亲属。所以我只有有限的时间来处理她所有的这些前拥有物。让我经历一下这些阶段吧。首先，她从一个空间很大、院子很大的房子搬了出来。我父亲去世后，这对她来说太吃力了。所以她搬进了一个成人社区，人们互相帮助，但这并不是真正的护理机构。然后她确实搬进了一个护理机构。现在，在每一个阶段，她都必须精简，我们必须共同决定保留什么，不保留什么。
And, of course, she always wanted to keep more than was physically possible in the space that she had available. At any rate, once my mother died, I was there, and I had only a few days to try to dispossess her of these last sets of possessions. And fortunately, I found that the staff in this care home were working. willing to take many of them. But there were certain things that were special. My father was an artist and certain of his art creations were really important to me. Some of my mother's jewelry, my daughter wanted to have, and she had come out and helped me for a time as well. But for the larger things, I couldn't take them back on the airplane with me. So I left them with a friend of my mothers and came back at a later stage to reclaim them. Nevertheless, I still found it very painful
当然，她总是想保留比她拥有的空间所能容纳的更多的东西。无论如何，我母亲去世后，我在那里，我只有几天时间试图处理她最后的一批拥有物。幸运的是，我发现这家护理院的工作人员愿意接收其中的许多东西。但有些东西很特别。我父亲是一位艺术家，他的一些艺术创作对我来说真的很重要。我女儿想要我母亲的一些珠宝，她也出来帮了我一段时间。但对于较大的东西，我无法把它们带上飞机。所以我把它们留给了我母亲的一位朋友，并在稍后阶段回来取回它们。尽管如此，我仍然觉得非常痛苦
to put things in dumpsters or to call 1-800 got junk and to immediately transform these things from meaningful possessions into junk, if you will, because they certainly weren't junk to my mother and over they junk to me in these memories. Other things like photos of people I didn't recognize with my mother on a European trip or something of that sort, it was easier to get rid of because if I knew these people, I'd give them the photos, but I didn't know any of them, and it was easy to get rid of those things. But things that I knew the meanings, even if I hadn't shared in them,
把东西扔进垃圾箱，或者打电话给“1-800-GOT-JUNK”，立即把这些东西从有意义的拥有物变成垃圾，如果可以这样说的话，因为它们对我母亲来说肯定不是垃圾，对我来说也不是，因为这些记忆。其他东西，比如我母亲在欧洲旅行时我认不出的人的照片之类的，处理起来就更容易了，因为如果我认识这些人，我会把照片给他们，但我一个都不认识，处理那些东西很容易。但那些我知道含义的东西，即使我没有参与其中，
it was like throwing away a piece of my mother. We come back to extended self here, and it was a sign of disrespect to treat these things in such a rough way. So that was really a difficult series of action. that I had to perform in order to get rid of those meaningful possessions. Yeah, it's really interesting to me how some possessions become sort of magical once they've been owned by someone you know, you loved, you cared about, or even a famous person. You know, it just imbues the item with something ineffable, but really important.
就像扔掉我母亲的一部分。我们在这里回到了“扩展的自我”，以如此粗暴的方式对待这些东西是对她的不尊重。所以，为了摆脱那些有意义的拥有物，我必须执行一系列非常困难的行动。是的，对我来说非常有趣的是，一些拥有物一旦被你认识、爱过、关心过的人，甚至是一个名人所拥有，就会变得有点神奇。你知道，它只是给物品注入了某种难以言喻但非常重要的东西。
And it just seems human nature to feel that way about things. Yeah, I think we all do that. I once met a woman who didn't want anything that wouldn't fit in a backpack because that would hinder her mobility. And of course, we think about digital nomads these days who want to be able to take a laptop and go anywhere in the world and have also known such people. And they usually tend to want to have a home base or to have some place that they're going to come back to. do at some point, even if it's a distant point in time like retirement. And so it's difficult to be truly unencumbered with things that we love with possessions, just as it's difficult to be unencumbered, if that would be the word, with people that we love.
对事物有这种感觉似乎是人性。是的，我想我们都这样做。我曾经遇到过一位女士，她不想要任何装不进背包的东西，因为那会阻碍她的流动性。当然，我们想到现在的数字游民，他们想要能够带着笔记本电脑去世界上的任何地方，我也认识这样的人。他们通常倾向于想要一个大本营，或者有一个他们会在某个时候回来的地方，即使那是一个遥远的时间点，比如退休。所以，很难真正摆脱我们所爱的东西，摆脱拥有物，就像很难摆脱我们所爱的人一样。
And people are a part of our extended selves as well. Now, we keep in touch via social media, and we may follow things that people do, but it's at a bit of a distance. and there's an old cartoon where people were sitting around a funeral hall and the coffin with the deceased was in front. And there were maybe half a dozen, two dozen people in the audience. One is saying to another, I thought there would be more people here. He had over 500 Facebook friends. Of course, these aren't real friends. And so the expectation that there would be many people there just from the social media was not a realistic one.
人们也是我们扩展自我的一部分。现在，我们通过社交媒体保持联系，我们可能会关注人们所做的事情，但那是在一定距离之外。有一个古老的漫画，人们坐在殡仪馆里，死者的棺材在前面。观众席上可能有半打、两打人。一个人对另一个人说：“我以为这里会有更多人。他有500多个Facebook好友。”当然，这些不是真正的朋友。所以，仅仅从社交媒体上期望那里会有很多人并不是一个现实的期望。
Some of those people may be dear friends, but most of them, we can't have 500 dear friends. Exactly. Yes. Well, Dr. Buck, this has been really interesting. I want to thank you for joining me today. I really enjoy talking with you. It's my pleasure. To listen to previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology, you can visit our website at www.
其中一些人可能是亲密的朋友，但大多数人，我们不可能有500个亲密的朋友。确实。是的。嗯，贝尔克博士，这真的很有趣。我想感谢您今天加入我的节目。我真的很喜欢和你交谈。这是我的荣幸。要收听《心理学谈话》之前的剧集，您可以访问我们的网站 www.
www.org, or you can find us on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you hear, please leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
www.org，或者您可以在Apple、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们。如果您喜欢所听到的内容，请留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康达扬（Chris Condayan）。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。